in this capsule we will see a
description and a premium for
the star algorithm then we are
in the context of research
heuristic we want to use the
heuristic search to solve a
problem that we formulated as a
search problem in a serious so
the heuristic search is actually
an approach that is very very popular
in artificial legs particles
and classical artificial intelligence
and in this case what's new by
report to search in a graph
that we already know the taitra is
we will add a tic nurse who
is used to guide research to
from a priori knowledge that we have
in relation to the fields of application
so that's a way for us as
user to insert
domain-specific knowledge
application for which we will do
a search in a serious
note that in this case graffiti it
is actually defined recurrently
and you implied that our
transition function if we apply it from
recurring way came would generate
the whole graph hell your pockets
generate the graffiti or complete before
start the search we will generate
recursively to the needs during
our exploration
so what is the star algorithm
a way to understand green algae
to stars it's like an extension of
the size 3 flu is actually it's
an extension that basically goes
incorporated the addition of a logistics
precisely to guide the search for
we hope to speed up the search
compared to astra and in fact one
will see that I'm dealing with a particular case
of 1 star so a ristic
we will define it specifically as
being a function h2n2 n is in us and
which returns us an estimate of the cost
staying between them n is the goal to
reach
so it's a kind of prediction of
cost that remains to be paid from a
hate to get by bus from the
path that will be optimal to troll and the
wall purpose obviously this is a prediction
that is, we do not have this
information there since we do not know the
optimal path but via the risk is
that we can influence the
research
pointing to paths that are more
promising because according to others
estimates the cost still to be paid for
what we had goal would be smaller the
and rustic then the development of
ristic
it's something we often see
in the works in intelligence
artificial either via a
very advanced definition of
logistics or via algorithms that
may try to learn
automatically and the restic is so
here in this capture we will see a
relatively general algorithm a pure
the code for which a little more generic
and for which 1 star is going to be a case
particular
before watching the boycott of their
star I'll all talked about two
variables that are important in
writing web execution
the first is the open variable which
actually goes to a list that
contains the walls that have not been
treated and specifically that fits
on the border of the graffl
explored until now has more to see
another variable claude who she's going
contain the nodes that have been processed
which is inside the
boundary delimited by open so by
example when running two stars
we could find a certain moment
an open list that would contain it's
three draws also in which cola
variable close
it would contain the knots here since
it's worthless we had to be
to be daring but he also
offered finally measure of execution
stars we will insert open stripping
withdrew then the nails go out and who
are treated will go to end up by
following in plos what will keep him
a list finally of all the nodes
who have already been treated
the knots in open on will keep them
sort they will be sorted according to
balleure f2m java is a species
destination of the potential value
one hour f2 so the function f on
call it the evaluations function and
this function of its purpose is to
to estimate the cost of the best path that
part of an initial increase that goes through
reindeer and who finally gets to the point
so fdn sadoine oath is a number
is it positive or zero since the
costs associated with the arts has been positive
minutes so uncertain an estimate
which is going to be positive or zero and that's
in some way an evaluation of the
potential of an honor to be part
to be part of the optimal path
in the graph
so as I said in open on
keep the knots in one order
growing in their value
fdn their function value
of evaluations and to do that we have
just to sort through insert to
the purchase every time we insert a
node in open so like that one
ensures that the list is
today and finally to take
the most promising nude at each
iteration of the star but we will have
simply learn the first we
in the red list
now definition a little better the
evaluation function so as I say
at the assessments function as much
to estimate the cost of the optimal path
between the novitiate the initial name by
whose purpose is specifically brain
head for the path that goes through the n
on the other hand obviously we do not know
does this shot there since for the
to know should actually know the
the optimal path will actually make known
the optimal path that goes everywhere
Lenin what we do not know about these offices
which is partly what we are looking for
so at any time by cons there is
something we know who is for
the part already explored that it is in
makes the optimal cost to get to this
we hockey so that's something
thing we know given the the
part of the globe that have explored one is
able to say what is the cost
associate as low as possible for the
explored part of getting to go
an initial as has not explored it m
so in the paintings what are we going to do
the party is that the function
of ebden assessments we will separate them into
two by the first part that we
was calling me jdn who's going to be the cost
precisely the best path that led
to this not since the original name
so it's really the best way
find until now to get
return to reindeer from the node
initial and then we will study
also the logistics function h of
hate who she will estimate the rest of the
So that's our function
logistics and its role is to try
to estimate the rest of the cost of the path
optimal who would leave hatred and who would
would make it to the end so we
could get a cost estimate
who is talking about an initial that goes from
shot of the path that speaks of an initial
which goes through reindeer and that ends
honor i'll goal by adding up
just gdn more hd and so in
the star is the structure that
learn our function from our
evaluations function savate lgdn plus
h 2 m and we will again assume
that hd n is always negative and that in
the more we have the property than if I evaluate h
of hate for the goal node so if n is
the nephew hd n is going to be zero
fectively scoci the way for himself
to make a bus from a view
logical it makes sense to return a
value of 0 looking at some examples
ristic functions for maybe
make the concept a little more tangible
so we speak the logistics function h
of hate in one application we had to
find the shortest way between
two cities we could use the
Euclidean distance on the map is
to say the final but the flying distance
of bird between a city n and the city
of destination
so it's actually we can
would be a way to estimate how much
our naughty by which we passed
to get to the city of
destination will allow us to
get as close as possible to our
city ​​of distance for puzzle game
like the top npws we could use
the number of tiles that are
currently misplaced
comparatively the configuration
final goal so actually this
are all tiles that will have to
be moved so we'll at least have had one
move to do for each of these
tiles da then in general if we have
a game makes the idea behind the
logistics function cdh estimates of a
somehow the quality of the
game configuration versus a
configuration that is winning
ok so that's what kind of notions there
we want to introduce in the
functions and ristic so let's look in
the detail the pseudo code for a
generic search algorithm in
a graph for which we did as
special cases when f corresponds to
the sum of j2h the star algorithm
so at the very beginning what we do is
we declare
a hate and as a bonus we will not be the
wall currently treated and prints vote
ific be one of the leading children of
hate declared our two lists to punk
lost and we will insert the initial name that
we passed there an argument our
function also we're going to insert the
initial name in open so does a
list with only one of his one's going
see a loop here that goes only
completed when a certain condition is
output will be detected in the
loop and at each iteration of the
loop we will do the operations
following
clearly so open obvious then in this
In this case, we'll go out and we'll get out of the
boucan returns to failure so we
would give a signal that would determine
that in fact there is no way to leave
of the initial name is to go to the beginning
so if this condition is not true
we can go here where she is going to be
assigned honor which at the beginning of the open
of Switzerland and the most promising draw
then we will remove m2 open then in
do we all go right now add it
in claude so the rest of the bo
the iteration of this iteration there in
the loop will do the treatment of
hatred
and then at the very end we could
add it to the very end but as long as
do we go add it to everything said
then if n matches so if we have
managed to get to our destination
an ubu but when if we go out of the
loop and we will return the path that
brought us to this draw at m
so it will be involved that's a little bit
as said otherwise we do not have all the
details but it implies from 1
it's possible to trace what was it
his parent to this one is the godfather of
his godfather is located until
initial name
if it's not our goal, well, what are we going to
do is add in open
leaders and this one it'll be the
successor leaders for the duds finally
of hate so essentially with the
new premiums that belong to the
list that we go back by
transition from
m enough of that for each of his
successors the un finally we're going
initialize the value for the value of
j2m premium a g2 n plus the cost associated with
go from nkm premium so we remember
that j2m is actually the cost
associate of the best path find
until now to get to
the n
so among others here I had to do initial
they have blue skin n 0 it would be equal
to zero so that will give us our
initial conditions and as and when
how far are we going to explore from
new paths by adding nude
successor well see essentially
get premium j2m values ​​that go
increase since each time we go
add the cost associated with the path of
spend an hour an hour we finally
when an anonymous then enters that
we will put so we will keep
the information that n premiums are our
parents who of the way who led
to a crime knew as a bonus the cee n
so we will assign if we want them
kind of variables chaparral 2nd
bonus to m then we'll check
does klose or open contain in
already makes a bonus that does not contain an em
prime bonus that equals a coin
we've already been to where we already
generated this successor before in
the execution of the algorithm is therefore
this is the first condition the second
condition is what is not appropriate to
generate a premium is actually more
promising that the node we generated
previously
if the most promising so 6th
to print smaller to pebbles f2m
bonuses premium and we will remove m premiums
premium of klose or open according to louis
was and we will insert a premium tower
now if subsequently 6th premium
is not in open so we are not in
added here
so 6th premium is not in open and
is not in close also well
it's a new path that we found
to get to this draw then we go there
i'll insert a bonus in opel and
noticed that the two times we insert
a node in open here here we insert in
gold growth said we place so
to maintain a growing order of 10
f2m values ​​for all the nudes in ok
so here we continue to draw as
it
maybe we'll go back
the path that leads that will lead to a
ubu either we'll go back a failure
because we will not have identified
we are not going to find a way that we
get to the destination
if they finally found that the
destination is not connected none
path between the initial name and another
destination
so that's the description of
two-star premium is so time
next capture let's do an example
to see exactly how you are this
that this algorithm runs it